à première vue c'est un cours d'anglais
plutôt banal madame bart devant une
vingtaine d'élèves de terminale mais
aujourd'hui ils révisent les svt les
sciences et vie de la terre car chaque
semaine cette classe européenne
travaille cette matière deux heures de
plus et en anglais c'est complètement un
autre contexte
franchement ça va être vraiment à
développer son anglais et à apprendre
des choses parce que en cours d'anglais
on n'apprend pas les organismes
génétiquement modifiés les constructions
géologique
c'est pas du tout les mêmes sujets moi
ça m'aide pas forcément à prendre plus
l'anglais mais ça me permettent
peut-être de d'élargir mon vocabulaire
ce sont les dnl les disciplines non
linguistiques dans ce lycée les classes
européennes suivent une matière en
anglais les svt l'histoire géo ou les
maths
au début en seconde quand ils commencent
ils sont toujours un petit peu
déstabilisé parce qu'on fait absolument
tout en anglais les consignes sont
passés en anglais toutes les
informations sont en anglais donc sa
salle et déstabilisent un petit peu au
début et en fait ici fait très très vite
romane suzanne et camille font partie
des 150 élèves de cette section
sur les 800 lycéens de l'établissement
des profils motivé avec de bonnes bases
en anglais niveau d'anglais il est un
peu plus élevée qu'en normal message
ça nous permet d'approfondir le vocal
des apps il faut pas vraiment avoir un
niveau non plus à excellent pour y aller
c'est des classes très mélangées donc a
pas de groupe qui se font entre moi j'en
euros soit et en os
on est tous ensemble pour le bac ça aide
pour plus tard si on veut aller étudier
à l'étranger et des choses comme ça on a
une dimension européenne sur l'autre
bague donc ça peut au moins enfin nous
mettre un mini certificat comme quand on
parle un petit peu anglais l'an dernier
une classe européenne a réalisé ces
bandes dessinées à partir de lettres de
soldats anglais
cette section permet aussi d'en
apprendre un peu plus sur d'autres pays